Hey!
Hello
Hi
Welcome to the
For All Mankind
time capsule.
The first season
of For All Mankind
kicks things off in 1969.
With the world watching
as the first man
lands on the moon.
But it's not Neil Armstrong,
it's a cosmonaut from
the Soviet Union.
That is the premise of the show.
What would change if the
Soviets landed first.
Spoiler Alert:
EV-ER-Y Thing.
First off, the cold war
only gets hotter
and the Soviets continue
to rock our world
with yet another first.
Putting the first woman
on the Moon.
So, President Nixon, no
watergate in our show folks,
tells NASA they
have two priorities
build a base on the
Moon and put a woman on it.
That's where all these bad ass
women come into play.
Including yours truly.
America's next
Apollo Astronauts.
My character Margo,
the first woman Flight
Controller at NASA,
tracks their progress
making sure these women
are up to the task.
You're an Astronaut!
And for my character Ellen,
certain things have not
progressed far enough,
and Ellen still needs
to hide her sexuality
or risk her career and
this incredible opportunity.
Against all odds this
crew of amazing women
knew they had to carry on. . .
and carry on they did with
my character Molly Cobb.
Smile
Taking her place on Apollo 15
Maybe don't smile.
and becoming the first
American woman in space.
Which is a milestone moment she
embraces with every
ounce of her typical...
enthusiasm.
People cheering...
I haven't done anything yet.
Ok. Ok. But she does
discover Lunar Ice.
Which brings humanity one step
closer to living on the Moon.
Houston are you
getting this onscreen?
That discovery leads to the
creation of Jamestown.
The first NASA base on the Moon.
How about that. We're
on the Moon to stay.
Things start to get
crazy when Apollo 23
explodes on the launch pad
stranding Ed, Gordo, and Dani
on Jamestown with
no plan of return.
There's trapped...
And then there's stuck on the
Moon and gonna die trapped.
And uh, as a result of this,
Gordo starts losing it big time.
Hey
-I saw one.
You saw what?
There's an ant in my...
-In your suit.
Ahh.
I can feel them.
They're all over me.
Calm down.
Ahh, I gotta get
my helmet off.
Get it off ahh.
-No.
If NASA were to find out
about Gordo's antics,
it's over for him.
So, to protect Gordo,
Dani heroically breaks
her own arm.
So Ed can send him
back to Earth with her
and NASA will be
none the wiser.
That's crazy. . .
You literally
broke your own arm?
Hey!
A hero's gotta do,
what a hero's gotta do.
That is true, but
that also means
Ed is now stuck out on the
Jamestown Moonbase
completely alone.
Back on Earth.
Margo takes Aleida
Rosales under her wing.
Oh my God
Congratulations.
As NASA continues to work
towards getting Ed home.
Meanwhile, Ed's wife Karen
is home with Shane,
their young son.
Go to your room!
Stressed, not knowing
when Ed will return.
Karen is stretched
thin and distracted.
What's going on?
Ma'am. I'm afraid
there's been an accident.
Devastated,
(door shuts)
Karen is forced to make
the most difficult
call of her life.
Karen?
(crying)
Ed spirals, and spirals.
Eventually, Ed snaps out of it
and he's alerted that
Ellen, aboard Apollo 24,
is floating past the Moon
without enough fuel to
slow down and land.
Margo, devises a plan
to use the lunar orbit
and sends Ed up into
space to rescue Ellen.
This cannot be
our-our best option.
I'm not gonna stand
here and let you. . .
This is my call!
I'm in command here —
Capcom, Let's go!
Yes ma'am.
Ok Ed. Coming up on 15 minutes
left in the window.
So, now or never.
After a few super
intense minutes.
Houston, we have capture.
Margo's plan proves successful
and Ed returns to the Moon,
safely, with Ellen.
Our first season ends with Ed
returning to Earth to mourn with
Karen and Ellen on Jamestown.
Is there anything you'd like to
say to anyone back home?
Umm.
Torn between her
heart and her career.
I know I don't say it enough,
but I miss you, and I love you
with all my heart. . .
Larry.
Oh wait! Not so fast.
We also launched a huge
rocket out of the ocean.
Oh my gosh!
It's massive!
It's amazing!